[Musique]
hypocrite et sa clique sont les amis des
uns que les autres et et sa crypte au
110 m sans talons
[Musique]
sacripant ce chenapan mais pas toujours
bon moment ou alors comme ça
pour moi si tu es sage de répondre tu
peux compter sur moi si tu es méchant ce
s'agrippant tumeur
être
[Musique]
bonjour les petits enfants perly popeck
n'est pas encore là il est toujours en
retard mais ne vous inquiétez pas je
sais faire marcher la machine
nous allons voir tout de suite s'il ya
eu des enfants sages
[Musique]
certains riverains j'ai tout cassé
surtout ne le dit pas on perd il faut
pas être il me battrai agrippant 4 tu
fais tu avais bien dit même pas toucher
à ma machine tu vas voir tu vas au pam
cherche
oh vous avez été saint sever et harris
[Musique]
ça y est
voyons un peu
où sont les enfants sages ça c'est bien
c'est bien je suis tout à fait content
hier les petits enfants du midi de la
france m'ont écouté il ya beaucoup
d'enfant sage de lyon jusqu'à la
méditerranée
mais je vois qu'à paris il n'y a pas de
nuages non plus sauf pour la télévision
ou un certain sacripant en aura
et enfin on va oui perly peu bête je ne
recommencerai plus
ces produits sains ces produits sont
bons alors voyons opah-ru nous allons
commencer notre palmarès à toulon à
toulon il ya eu beaucoup de bons enfants
aujourd'hui est celui qui a été le plus
sage comment s'appelle-t-il attend
on freine on commence par un c c'est un
petit garçon ou une petite fille aux
oeufs
ouah c'est une fille dont le prénom
commence tard c'est peut-être une
christiane oui 6 non et christelle gema
le firmament 334 boulevard général
brosset toulon 83 ces quelques
départements ça le vin sur le bord de la
mer la mer la mer méditerranée at elle
est une petite fille de 3 ans qui est
très sage elle ne fait jamais en rage et
sa maman elle n'est pas comme moi avec
des hypothèques manon alors non
heureusement sinon magie ne l'aurait
sûrement pas proposé pour le palmarès
c'est très bien ma petite christelle 1
et continue à être bien sage et embrasse
maintenant maintenant voyons où habite
deuxième enfant ça
mais moi je connais blanquefort c'est
dans la gironde qui suit à l'ief en
vacances et c'est très joli bond est un
petit garçon et et oui et oui oui c'est
un petit garçon blond qui s'appelle 1 1
c'est un edouard emile il s'appelle
edward labourdette
il habite la résidence dur hôtel à 21 à
blanquefort dans la gironde blanquefort
je crois bien l'avoir déjà rencontrée
oui il a deux ans milite très très
mignon il aime beaucoup jouer mais il
est très obéissants et son papa et sa
maman ancion très content enfin moi je
suis heureux mon petit edouard de
t'inscrire au palmarès et je t'envoie de
grosses bises 2 3 up haute-garonne
aucamville
vous en savez des choses c'est un petit
garçon s'est pas demandé à la machine
ces hommes comme les bernois n'ont
d'abord c'est une petite fille et de
plus le père noël n'est pas un petit
garçon mais un vieux grand-père un no
comment s'appelle thème c'est nathalie
berthezène rues-des-vignes castelginest
à aucamville dans la haute garonne
bravo nathalie je sais que tu es très
ordonnée et que tu ranges bien tout est
à faire
mais moi je sais que tu t'occupes de ta
petite soeur sandrine qui a deux ans et
que tu as cinq ans et que tu vas à
l'école et que tu passes ton temps à
colorier
c'est très bien mais j'espère que tu
nous enviera à ses jours un beau dessin
oui bah onatel bob maintenant alors un
peu comme toi un peu de calme owens a
perdu beaucoup de routes sont belles
c'est l'hiver
et voilà rond mais dépêchez-vous père
l'hypothèse est petit ami inquiet du
tournoi sacripant c'est un piètre 1 oui
bon
le creusot 71 c'est quoi ce santé 11 la
saône-et-loire très beau et c'est un
petit garçon non non c'est une petite
fille
son prénom commence à m
et bien c'est nathalie encore une
oui et nathalie jacques oups 20 rue
d'assas le creusot 71 200 à gagner au
palmarès des enfants sages
elle est très sage elle chante toute la
journée
bien qu'elle n'ait que qu'attend il
s'amuse gentiment avec sa petite soeur
christelle qui n'a qu'un an et demi
en plus elle est très affectueuse avec
sa maman c'était bien alors nous
embrassons très fort toi est à petit
seuls
il y aura une belle surprise tout à
l'air froid
sacripant je n'ai pas encore fini il ya
d'autres enfants sages à récompenser ça
c'est si facile l'année dernière au
festival c'est dans les bouches du rhône
at a bien ou encore une petite fille qui
s'appelle son prénom commence par un c
comme caroline clos où il a dit non non
non c'est cécile piqué habitants à
aix-en-provence résidence des cyprès 5
boulevard ferdinand de lesseps est
vraiment qu'elle mérite bien d'être
inscrite au palmarès
oui oui oui elle a 6 ans et un petit
faire du six mois qui est très très
turbulent oui oui malgré tout elle est
très sage et très patient avec lui et
puis elle aide sa maman à faire les lits
à mettre le couvert et enlever la
poussière
bravo sicile en moi je n'ai jamais voulu
faire aller et nous avons encore le
temps de désigner un autre en france
alors nous allons à mes yeux dans l'euro
à un ictus allons voir si c'est un gars
ou une fille et un petit garçon son
prénom commence en fait elle s'appelle
dit oui ou gaston gabriel louis
il s'agit de gilles teisseire il habite
la gendarmerie de mes yeux il est jean
bouin non mais non c'est un petit garçon
est bien d'avoir six ans il est très
sage car depuis quelque temps il a signé
une trêve avec sa soeur avec laquelle il
se disputait souvent c'est comme moi
avec le quart hip hop haute voix mais
lui il la respecte la trêve il ne lui
fait plus de niches même il lui prête
ses jouets ah ça c'est très bien oui
trop occupé à lipopette lui ne vais pas
de jamais sa machine magique où tu as vu
ce que ça donne quand tu la touche par
an 1 1 bon mes petits amis bravo je vous
félicite
alors maintenant attention où j étais
sers de mes yeux
cécile piqué d'aix-en-provence med ali
jacou du creusot in nathalie
peuvent-elles d'aucamville edouard
labourdette de blanquefort et christelle
gma à mon signal vous allez ouvrir votre
porte vous trouverez un préposé des ptt
qui vous apportera vous êtes prêts alors
hop
allez-y et vous les autres enfants je
vous dis à demain
il est temps de faire un gourou tout aux
bons soins